there's Avengers behind this room
what's the vehicle you're gonna die
oh yeah yeah yeah what's going on reject
nation it's Greg al-baqir with the kylo
Ren don't say your name I speak for you
now
I'm your host Greg album the kind of red
ball across social media
he is Kyle Yzerman and he has a channel
fan theory on YouTube listen to title he
might guess what it's about since you
have a channel called fan Theory I
thought let's do a discussion video
today the big talk around MCU who's
going to die in the MCU who's going to
die in Avengers infinity war I have a
theory now that I looked over the cast
list and didn't do any homework on this
video I see you have notes something I
did not do because why would I do that
I'm Greg Elvis
so Kyle yes before you go into your
thoughts I will share with you who I
think is going to die that's here easily
spider-man no doubt about that like why
would they keep him around
what spider-man zone for is killing him
off way too early ending his franchise
as early as possible don't let him wrap
it up I say announce homecoming 2 and
then don't do home don't do spider-man 2
and do it if they did that I can I can
assure you that audiences
internationally would be pretty
surprised yes well I think this is the
most accurate fan prediction yuen yuen
is your partner yeah will die and all
right are they going to shoehorn Miles
Morales is quickly into spider-man X's
possible no I don't I don't believe that
what do you think will die right off the
bat vision vision vision would be number
one and the reason why is because
visions essence in his soul is always in
the Infinity stone in his head which is
the mind stone so I guess in some some
way he's still alive in the stone
but like physically speaking I don't
think you'll be with us after at least
the fourth Avengers film what are they
trying to destroy the stones he can't
destroy the stone that would just
destroy the universe yeah no I don't
think you can destroy the stones but to
get if that house is trying to collect
the stones he would probably take it out
of visions head and kill him correct
ah you need that stone so visions got to
die that's a great fan theory who do you
think and one who do I actually think
will die yeah all right well if Marvel
gets a little bold and then they kill us
I mean the obvious contender has been
Captain America blue even thinking
Captain America's going to die for a
long time sure I feel most likely that
he will die they just been setting him
up to die I have an argument against
that though why what's your argument
Captain America and Tony Stark are both
kind of father figures to Spider Man
during the Civil War in the comic books
we've had plenty of Tony Stark going on
here with Peter Parker there's been
several rumors about the next spider-man
film the next sequel to it where there's
going to be a pretty obvious pretty can
make sense choice for who's going to be
kind of his new mentor in the second
spider-man yeah yeah
Captain America yeah so I don't really
know I think if he dies he's still
coming back but the thing is he kind of
worried right but not really I guess he
was frozen but still like you know it
was the impression that he he died until
he left post credits scene of course I
just think it cap dies and I think he
very well could and it makes the most
sense of the comic books I also think
they're gonna bring him back from the
dead for spider-man
I would think honestly if I if I had it
was one that I would honestly think
would die it would be direct I think
they would kill off a guardian oh
absolutely and I think Drax will be the
contender to go and they're talking
about how light down the road they'll
apply be a brand new guardians of the
galaxy cast like a different set of
guardians yeah in total absolutely I
mean Marvel's going to keep this turning
like even over even though everything's
built up to this infinity war there's
still so much more story and they can
amplify they've already changed so much
from the comic book so even though
Thanos is the Big Daddy of the comics it
doesn't mean that they can't change it
in the Cinematic Universe to someone
even worse than that and totally don't
know so and and direct hate Stannis oh I
also think they've run out of huh for
watching guardians to them like you guys
have like limited ideas for Drax left I
think yeah I mean I think to make him
feel more significant and matter more
you have to feel like you'll probably do
maybe not exactly a yondu thing but some
type of sacrificial thing in ordered I
absolutely didn't out and be a memorable
hero as part of the guards aghasura
thanks for watching guardians to him
like Jack seems kind of a necessary now
yeah so I feel like they would do
something to make him feel more
necessary
perhaps he dies in that heroic way yeah
and speaking of people who have an issue
with Ennis nebula from guardians who was
kind of well she was definitely a
villain in the first movie she is likely
going to be true hey if you sorry
spoiled her yeah she is likely to betray
Santos and when that happens thinness is
not going to tolerate it she's been kind
of you could see her fate was sealed a
while ago so I see a note here talking
about Hawkeye yes Jeremy Renner seems
over it yes Jeremy Renner is not really
sure what his character is there's been
a lot of talks about Marvel they like
the character or Hawkeye but Jeremy
Renner personally is like who even is
this guy like what is his purpose why
like they gave him this story in
Avengers 2
I think Hawkeye is easily the best
character out of the MCU explain there
are no words he did for that good guy is
that good he's just that good I think I
think he's cool I just think they need
to soup him up a little bit they
souped-up Spider Man they should soup up
Hawkeye a little bit more than what they
have he's surprisingly one of the more
two-dimensional character yeah but you
see I think like it for infinity war
they got to be more bold and like
killing off Hawkeye so much of an
obvious choice is such a secondary
character maybe even a third dari
character is not like significantly if
he dies like a bummer but yeah
he's an easy kill that the characters
might be you know motional II involved
with speaking of emotionally involved
Nick Fury he is the originator of the
Avengers and he has no powers other than
to be cool but I think to make that a
scary you got to kill off one of the
superpower
Scarlet Witch Scarlet Witch yeah
absolutely
why do you hate women Kyle I love women
there's no one more powerful really in
Marvel Comics in so many in so many
universes whether it's x-men or Avengers
because she's living both she is
insanely powerful she actually stopped
all mutants existed by simply saying no
more mutants like she is a powerhouse
and the Cinematic Universe has barely
even scratched surface of her powers and
I think that when they start to they're
going to have Stannis take her out just
to prove a point to the audience that
anyone can be taken out and there's
nothing more like a more powerful trope
than to kill the most powerful character
in the film to leave everything of
impact you know my theory is a Santos
will die it's a good one it's a good one
Ian you know I don't know for sure but
yeah that's a good bit good that's a
good choice okay so let's look at this
our options that we have so far on the
list here to go who will be the one they
kill off cap Scarlet Witch okay
Hawkeye Nick Fury okay Drax so between
those five who are the main one who's
the main one you think will die kind of
no vision in that list uh and no vision
okay vision yeah so you really think is
vision that if I had to pick out of all
the ones that we've listed vision
wouldn't be my first and cap would be my
second okay okay
yeah mine would be Black Panther has
marvelous races and Nick Fury cos Marvel
is racing what what about Falcon yeah I
mean oh hey - yeah they're always good
that's just the way Marvel runs their
[ __ ] I did kids tracks in Captain
America so we're gonna be up yeah yeah
yeah no I think those are solid choices
for sure if they're super bold killa
Tony Stark they're not going to do that
but Robert Downey jr. is getting
surprisingly even for Marvel little
expensive really yeah I'll figure
something out
I mean they have so far but I mean he's
he's always down for more he's more
recently said that he actually finally
open to doing an Ironman for I would be
okay with I think you could do old man
Sark I don't want to see it but I think
he didn't I mean he could be Iron Man
easily into his old age I mean because
it's not as my new strength as much as
it's smart you know so as long as he
doesn't like it like it Alzheimer's or
something and we well here jag would
probably want to retire because it's
physically exhausting yeah although Hugh
Jackman still says that if for some
reason Wolverine could come into the MCU
he would be Wolverine once again hmm
I would watch that oh absolutely
one beam and then done yeah I mean they
could do it still like I thought that it
wasn't possible am i well they've
already wrecked it and they have like
the same people and different universes
but they could because Marvel has gone
beyond just robotics and technology and
space travel and other dimensions like
yeah they've gone above and beyond it we
could easily jump between worlds they
could literally just say oh you're in
the 20th Century Fox universe sure
or they could get Jesus Christ in the
MCU they could that would be everyone it
would be a pretty baller superhero you
got to get all the superheroes to fight
Satan
imagine that I would watch that
I feel like Falcon would be very
necessary I mean there is Mephisto in
the Marvel Universe and that's basically
saying basically Satan and actually
Satan or two very safe we're crossing
dimensions why not
which sheets what do you guys think well
Jesus being the next MCU Bill
pull up subscribe to the real rejects
who do you think a real question who do
you think you will die and adventures is
benedi horn hey subscribers very chic
click that notification bell that man's
the Cuyler man on everything
he is also fan Theory channel on YouTube
that's me hey Kyle
yes great people have been commenting on
our weight loss you're the one who
helped me really get to my point and
weight lossing stuff because one fills
you a patreon video and talk about it
let over at our patreon
yay